[Music]
you've discovered a doorway to another
realm and now you and your brother are
off exploring the wonderful world of
paradoxical fantastically paradoxical
creatures crawl run and fly around you
and then you see the troll it's catching
all the creatures in an enormous net you
bravely step forward and demand it let
them go the troll laughs if you're such
a fan of paradoxes it says then I'll
make you an offer if you say something
true I'll release all these creatures
you're about to say you are a troll but
before you can the troll grabs your
brother if you say something false he
continues then I'll release your brother
your statement can only be a single
sentence and as you can see I hate
paradoxes more than anything if you try
to cheat by saying something paradoxical
like this statement is false then I'll
eat your brother and the creatures what
true false statement can you say to
force the troll to free your brother and
the paradoxical creatures
this seems like an impossible situation
but incredibly you can say something
that will force the troll to release all
its prisoners this is an example of
coercive logic invented by the great
logician and puzzle creator Raymond
Smolyan the tricks mullion came up with
involves saying a statement whose truth
or false Ness depends on what you want
the troll to do your statement still has
to be carefully crafted for example if
you were to say you are going to free
the creatures and my brother the troll
could respond that's false I'm only
going to free your brother similarly if
you said you will free the paradoxes the
troll could say that's true and free the
paradoxes but watch what happens if you
say you will free my brother the
statement can't be false because if it
were the troll by its own rules would
have to free your brother that would
make the statement paradoxically true
and false but the troll hates paradoxes
and would never willingly create one so
his only option is for the statement to
be true if you will free my brother is
true then the troll has to release her
brother and by its own rules the troll
has to free the creatures as well since
you set a true statement by wielding
just five words like a logical scalpel
you've forced the troll to free all its
prisoners as the troll stops off in
anger the paradoxes cheer you for
winning them their freedom and promise
to lead you to the treasure at the top
of the stairs if you can reach it
there are two chests one will open if
you say a true statement and the other
will open if you say a false statement
one contains treasure and the other will
release a deadly gas but you don't know
whether the treasure is in the true or
the false chest what should you say to
get the treasure and live to tell the
tale this bonus riddle comes courtesy of
our sponsor brilliant commit to
advancing your personal growth by
visiting brilliant dot org slash ted-ed
and the first 833 of you to use that
link will get a 20% discount off the
annual subscription